hundreds of studies are underway to test
therapies to cure koban 19:00 one major
focus is the use of what's called
convalescent plasma while still
experimental early results from a
clinical trial multiple clinical trials
in fact show that plasma transfusions
are both safe and effective the therapy
transf uses antibody rich plasma from
recovered patients into sick patients
many of the doctors who are coming
forward are members of Orthodox and
Hasidic Jewish communities interesting
ly enough senior medical correspondent
dr. Turner Rula spoke with a patient and
his donor after almost a month in the
hospital this is the moment 59 year-old
Robert Kovacs longed for going home I
was in bed for the first two weeks then
we get to week 3 and week 3 was like two
steps forward five steps back for weeks
Kovacs was dependent on a high flow
oxygen concentrator at this point I'm
ready to do anything because I could see
that my oxygen was not changing that's
when doctors found him a match for a
plasma transfusion user of all the way
to New York just to donate sure
Jacob Markowitz recovered from the virus
in March he's one of the now tens of
thousands of Orthodox and Hasidic Jews
who are donating their plasma to help
others any other peoples were suffering
with the corona lights corona virus has
ravaged the Orthodox Jewish community
likely at a rate higher than any other
ethnic group according to public health
data
there's many families that don't have
fathers or mothers there's hundreds and
hundreds of newly created orphans in our
community Marty Searle is behind a
grassroots movement to mobilize members
of the community who have recovered from
the virus to donate their blood plasma
the tradition that everything we have in
life is something to be utilized we have
the gift of recovery we have the gift of
antibodies
our community cannot just sit and enjoy
and we all feel this intense obligation
to go and to give it back you can think
about those antibodies as sort of Pakman
operating in your bloodstream that are
going around kind of gobbling up the
viruses dr. Michael Joyner heads the
convalescent plasma program at the Mayo
Clinic the lead institution conducting
clinical trials and research on the
centuries-old treatment one of the
reasons we've been able to treat five
six seven hundred people a day on some
days is because of the generosity that
Orthodox community he estimates roughly
there have been 13,000 plasma
transfusions to treat kovat 19 in the US
and at least half of all donations have
come from Orthodox and Hasidic Jews is
this the biggest number nationally that
we've ever seen in this country in terms
of use of asthma oh yes by far and
likely the largest anywhere in the world
ever what kinds of results have we seen
with plasma transfusions well the most
important thing we can tell people right
now with some certainty is it appears to
be safe the next phase is to begin to
understand efficacy we have many many
positive anecdotes one of those
anecdotes is Cove axes it was like a
miracle I could feel the difference
immediately I really think that this got
me back to where I am today sitting on
my deck with my beautiful family just a
few days after receiving plasma therapy
oh that's got this special opportunity
to meet his donor Jacob the man he
believes helped save his life waiting
for this minute so excited so excited to
say thank you for not from the bottom of
my heart for really sure like wow this
is the best thing for me in my life
that's the kind of help you let's make
me my day my year my whole life's make
me I'm so emotional after this this
meeting I feel so connected with you
good well we're to say we're the same
now we're brothers from different
mothers yes yes and dr. taryn Narula
joins us now doctor
your piece just made clear it's the
donors who are coming forward from the
Orthodox and Hasidic Jewish community
not necessarily the doctors I misspoke
earlier but it raises a question of how
does one become a donor in the first
place well the first thing is you just
have to meet basic general requirements
for blood donation you have to be
symptom free from kovat for about 14
days and you have to have lab documented
evidence that you did in fact have kovat
as far as how to find out where to go
you can go online the Red Cross the
American Association of blood centers
lots of places you can get information
there's actually a new campaign called
the fight is in a stork started by
multiple organizations academic
institutions and companies where you can
go online to that website and they can
screen you through the website to see if
you're eligible and put in your zip code
and actually tell you where you can go
locally to donate but it's so inspiring
to see this you know we focus so much on
the tragedy associated with kovat but to
see these bright spots of humanity
really coming together and showing just
how altruistic these tens of thousands
of Americans are it's it's just
fantastic and inspiring here here dr.
Narula well said that's a great note